Dạy là một cái điều
Điều lông rất là
Trong trái tim mẹ về bài mật khi nhất bố hơi là những lâm mẹ và gái lĩnh của em lúc
Thì không đứa nè tấn khỏi
Thôi là những lúc mắt được
In yu lùi cạnh thấy là mẹ ngắn và bị ổn
Thì mà trong những cái khoảng thời gian khó hành
Bộng lưu gõn rất nhiều mọi người đã phân trạng vào uống hủy nhìn
Trong đó có ché đình mẹ, cho chí chục cập tế
và đặc biệt là quý vị tránh dạ.
Bình như nhỏ là bảo vệ khoảng thời gian người như vật ra,
sẽ như họ có ốc quốc.
Bối là mấy như đăng mục kết bài gì đó.
Như lùng được mọi người quay tâm nước như là được mọi người đã lại chứng kái con nghen là
không nghe như người như người dây vui từ quá.
Không nghe như người như thì họ có xin vi
có một chụi đại họ ở ốc.
Nhìn người như rất là năng lộ,
mà kinh khẩm nghen mà kinh bình lộng như vậy,
cho ý như cái nghen là mừng lũ nhìn được tư dù anh thăm của món
và bất tránh đáu, chính là cái sử dòng hành.
Tìm mà món lũ lũ đại hình mình.
Như đình là phục kết điều.
Lũ lũ đất là...
Chúng ta thì mình về bài mật khi nhất bố hơi là những lần này,
và cái những ý quay nốt.
Thì không như nè tấn khỏi.
Thà hẹn gước mắt được.